こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん、趣味はありますか？
あの僕の趣味と言ったら基本的に
インドアで
まあ基本的に遊戯王するかゲームするか
ぐらいしか無いんですけどもー
ちょっと新たな趣味を見つけようというわけでも無いんですけどもー
あのー
ちょっとゴルフやってみたいなーと思っちゃって
で、まずゴルフって何がいいかというとー
あのボールと
（ボールをゴルフクラブで打つふり）
なんていうんだっけ　アレ
ゴルフの・・
えーっと　スイングクラブ・・・
えーっと
何だっけ
ゴルフクラブだ！そう
そうです
ゴルフクラブを買おうと思いまして
なんか　すごいのがあったんで買ってきました。
一応この中に入ってるんですけど開けてみましょう
なんか　ゴルフクラブって皆さん
多分硬いイメージがあると思うんですよ
金属の棒でゴルフのボールを思いっきり
かっとばしてぶっ飛ばしていくっていう
イメージがあると思うんですけども
私が見つけたのはただのゴルフクラブではございません
今回買ったのはこちら
ほい！
おお～！（満悦）
はいこちら
っていうゴルフクラブです
僕コレ買って思ったんですけどー
なかなか高かったですけども
ん～
はい　で、これなんですけども、
普通のゴルフクラブとは何が違うんでしょうか
たぶんなんですけど
パッと見てもわかんないと思うんですけども、
僕も多分言われないとわかんないし
見た目的にも特になんの変哲もない感じに見えると思いますが
このゴルフクラブ、何がすごいといいますと
いきますよいきますよ
なんと
すごくない？これでしなるからねー
あっ、ああああああああ
ゴルフのことよくわかんないんですけど
コレなんか、しなるゴルフクラブらしくてー
普通にこうやって打つじゃないですかー
普通に打つと
ああ　すごい
いやぁ、もうこれしなり方が...
しなり方がもう尋常じゃねえぞコレ
本当にこれでゴルフできんのかってくらいしなってるんですけどもー
で、これアマゾンで買ったとき書いてあったんですよ
これはもうねぇ、あの、ゴルフクラブに見えて
ほらもう、しなりかたがほんと尋常じゃねぇ
これすげぇ使えるなと思いまして
みなさんの想像しているゴルフクラブは
硬くてこのまっすぐな金属でバコーンって打つやつだと思うんですけど
これはもうしなりますから
そもそも
ゴルフクラブってムチのようにしなって打てるんですかね
ほらもう完全にムチ
ムチムチムチ　ムチのようにしなt...
うわぁぁぁ（衝撃と絶望と愛しさと切なさと）
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　や↑し↑も↑や↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓し↓もぉ↑　や↑し↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓し↓もぉ↑　やぁ↓し↓も↓　や↓し↑も↓やぁ↑しぃ↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！もっ！やっ！しっ！♬
ええっ！？！？！？！？？？？？？？？？？？？？！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！？？？？？？！えっえっ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
（ざわ。。。。ざわ。。。。）
こんなはずじゃなかったのに
ち”ょ”っ”と”待”っ”て”え”
ムチじゃないじゃん
もうムチってもっとこう
もうムチじゃないじゃん
えーーーー本当はこっからですよぉ・・・
ほんとはここからもっとしたい動画があったんですよ
なんか　本当は僕がブチ切れて
めちゃくちゃ硬いはずのゴルフクラブを
なんか、力で捻じ曲げて
みんなが怖気づく動画を
撮ろうと思ったんですけど
まあ
こういう日も
ええんちゃう？
さーせんした！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！